[Music]  America was founded on the idea that  human beings are born with natural  rights such as the rights to life  liberty and property a person who holds  this view of rights makes no demands on  others except that they respect those  rights today however many Americans talk  about rights to a college education  state-of-the-art medical care and even  birth control pills these are rights  understood as entitlements and a person  who holds this view of rights is making  claims on other people's money and  resources  this understanding of rights not only  sets citizens against each other but it  undermines the whole idea of natural  rights learn more about the constitution  at Constitution minute calm